hey welcome to the monitor not just any
episode of the monitor it is the 20th
episode of the monitor I almost at 20th
anniversary but it's really the first
anniversary if we were going in 20
episode seasons but we're not so it's
just the 20th episode of the monitor and
they assured me that there would be CGI
balloons falling from the sky and
covering me in my chair because it is a
gala event but even if the balloons
don't show up from post-production and I
have no way of knowing if they will
we're still going to have a great week
as always I'm puter Rubin senior editor
at Wired this week we have a book that
purports to tell the secret history of a
much beloved cultural brand we have a
video game that lets you kill it will
like ice cube in the early 90s but first
we have a very good week of television
not only does Walking Dead come back for
its third season sunday on AMC but what
I consider to be the best night on
comedy is starting tonight this very
evening on FX and that is it's always
sunny in philadelphia which has been
around for a while and you know it and
the league which although it's been
around for a while I feel like not
enough people know what so let's talk
about that Seinfeld took this dynamic of
selfish jackasses who were friends
wreaking havoc on the life of those
around them both always sunny and the
league take that and he ratcheted up
about 12 million degrees the lead in
particular is about a group of longtime
friends in the Chicago area who have a
fantasy football league sounds fine
sounds like if you don't like football
and you don't play fantasy football you
wouldn't be into it wrong wrong again
because the husband-and-wife team that
right the league somehow will not only
do the encouraged improv among the
incredible cast which includes comedians
Nick Kroll Paul Scheer Jon Lajoie and a
few others filmmaker mark Duplass and
his real-life wife Katie Hazleton are in
it but not only do they encourage improv
but they have somehow managed to really
evoke the the rhythms and the and and
the relationships of a long time group
of friends you really believe that these
guys have known each other for 15 or 20
years it's really solid that way and
because it's a little lowbrow people
assume it's not smart wrong again I say
wrong this is just it's fantastic
it's it's the the atmosphere of the show
is just so true to life even though you
might not know people who are like this
it's so utterly believable that you go
along with it and ton of NFL player
cameos that is not going to change this
year they got a bunch of fun ones
planned that is tonight on FX it's
always sunny in philadelphia and the
league both back for a new season I
could not be more excited but now let's
talk about video games you know what I'm
tired of and I say this as a bay area
resident I am tired of steampunk but it
doesn't matter because one of the best
video games of the year is rooted firmly
in that aesthetic and that is dishonored
which is out this very week from
Bethesda Softworks for xbox ps3 and the
pc bethesda of course behind last year's
Elder Scrolls 5 skyrim the incredible
Skyrim is back with a first-person
stealth adventure game let's just call
it that you play an assassin in this
played racked town in the early part of
the 20th century with a kind of magical
futuristic steampunk thing at any rate
you wake up framed for a crime you
didn't commit as the bodyguard and
instead you turn assassin with the help
of all these magical powers that you are
mysteriously bequeathed bestowed with
whatever be e word you like but now you
are beside yourself with the ability to
kill as many people as you want or as
few people as you want you to go through
the game and not kill anyone if you like
you can possess animals you can teleport
from here to there you have all these
crazy gadgets and skills it is it's just
ridiculously fun it is a imagine a
first-person assassin's creed bioshock
deus ex on mass shuttle and that's what
you have actually some of the devs on
the game do have experience on bioshock
and deus ex and and it really shows it
is a remarkably imaginative game they
even let you turn off as much of the
heads-up display as you want so you can
play in truly minimal style
it's not an easy game but it is a
rewarding game it is out this week it is
dishonored definitely definitely a
pickup back to you okay thank you for
that well let's talk about books because
I I sit in front of a shelf of them yet
I feel like I don't necessarily come off
as the literary erudite character that
is meant to be a VOC by this chair and
these books so let's talk about a book
this week in particular let's talk about
this book that just magically appeared
from my lap Marvel Comics the untold
story by Sean how and what's remarkable
is everyone thinks they know the history
of Marvel Comics oh there was Stanley
and oh there's Jack Kirby and oh there's
Steve did Cohen Oh everything went belly
up in the 90s and oh it's kind of good
this right about now but commissures
earned something as much all well and
good but the reporting that went into
this book is actually pretty spectacular
the the conversations that he manages to
reenact through his interviews the the
mood in the office the actual creative
projects in the atmosphere on those is
astounding if you are at all new to
comics and by at all I mean if you
didn't start reading comics in the 60s
when Stanley developed so many of the
seminal Marvel characters then you do
kind of owe it to yourself to read this
it gives anyone from a die-hard comic
fan to a total neophyte in the medium a
really incredible foundation and
grounding of comic history because it's
Marvel you're not necessarily going to
get the DC history but it does give you
a sense of how one of the most dominant
brands and comics today evolved waned
and waxed contracted and expanded for my
money comics now are actually doing
really well there's a lot of creativity
right the premium is on good writing and
there's room for a lot more houses than
Marvel but almost no one would exist
without Marvel so kind of the history of
Marvel is in some microcosmic way cynic
doke away a history of comics itself so
i recommend this read very high way i'm
not finished with it yet I am plowing
through it though and it is really a lot
of fun and it's informative so pick it
up but that's it for the 20th episode of
the monitor we're now in syndication so
you can probably catch us right after
the ten o'clock news on some crappy
channel but until next week you can
email us at the monitor at wired.com
with any sort of comments and criticism
that your little heart desires and until
then inspirational catchphrase here